people need to know that the shaking is
not over you will feel it on the East
Coast
hey there's downtown LA where we shoot
hashtag no I'm dead I'm dead in the
trailer for San Andreas we see a mega
quake destroying downtown Los Angeles
San Francisco and the Hoover Dam whoo
good thing earthquakes only affect
famous landmarks I'm drew Coolidge and
I'm here to help answer the question and
the earthquake and the movie San Andreas
really happened let's find out
this is hashtag news Hollywood has
finally made a movie about the biggest
fear of every California resident we're
not afraid of skin cancer Scientology or
smog suffocation we're afraid of
earthquakes because those do not start
with an S so where do birth quakes come
from well the Earth's crust is basically
a sexy jigsaw puzzle of continental and
oceanic plates constantly ramming
sliding grinding it's super hot if it
didn't involve massive structural damage
and death most earthquakes occur along
the lines where these plates come into
contact called Falls the most famous one
in California is called you guessed it
San Andreas you didn't guess it I'm
sorry but we have to move on scientists
measure the magnitude of quakes on the
Richter scale which rates the amount of
energy released from a quake from one to
ten but six isn't slightly more powerful
than a five each number on the scale
increases by a power of 10 meaning an
earthquake measured as a six is actually
ten times greater than a level-five
earthquake and a seven is 100 times
greater than a five math can kill you oh
look out Matt well this is all
theoretical but what kind of real-world
damage can one of these babies do well
an earthquake between a three and a four
point nine may knock some stuff off your
shelves and make you nervous a 5 to 7
can create some moderate to severe
damage cracked foundations grown men
screaming but a 7 to 8 like the recent
one in Nepal this is a major earthquake
that can cause buildings to collapse an
extensive destruction and 8 to 9 is
really scary like the one in Japan in
2011 it can destroy even earthquake
resistant buildings and cause
huge tsunamis if it's located off the
coast then there's a 9.0 and above like
San Andreas or the infamous 9.5 in Chile
in 1960 the only earthquake of its size
ever recorded these babies can result in
total destructions of cities permanently
changing the ground topography which
brings us to a 10-point Oh is this type
of mega wave even possible scientists
say yes theoretically but in real
realistic reality it's not the magnitude
of an earthquake is related to the
length of the fault on which it occurs
the longer the fault the larger the
earthquake but on our planet there is no
fault long enough to generate a
magnitude 10 earthquake except for the
one on your mother's but however a 2006
study concluded that the San Andreas
Fault
had reached sufficient stress level for
the earthquake we all fear the big one
the study said the information available
suggests that the fault is ready for the
next big earthquake it could be tomorrow
it could be 10 years from now 10 years
from now that's today never fear because
the rock will save us all when he puts
his nearly superhuman strength to good
use by flying a helicopter now even if
the big one hits it probably won't go
down like it does in the movie I mean
the earth won't literally crack open the
earth will literally crack open Paul
come on what did I just say crack open
no I know what I just said I mean what
did I save that's exactly what I'm
saying never mind
you know what just go have some Merlot I
am not drinking any Merlot the earth
will not crack open earthquakes come
from friction of two plates hitting and
sliding against each other if they just
separated like they do in movies all the
time there would be no friction to cause
the quake the movie also depicts a large
tsunami hitting San Francisco in reality
an earthquake stemming from the San
Andreas Fault Line wouldn't produce a
tsunami as the tsunami can only occur if
the focus or hypocenter of the
earthquake lies in a body of water the
San Andreas Fault only covers land so
there we have a giant earthquake we'll
all be killed by land ray San Andreas
like so many other disaster movies
before it takes liberties with Mother
Nature and shows us a worst case
scenario that
isn't even possible but earthquakes are
very real and very destructive the
victims of Nepal still need your help if
you want to lend a hand there's a link
in the description to show you how the
earthquakes are notoriously difficult to
predict so remember preparation is key
that end training on the earthquake ride
at Universal Studios huh that's not very
helpful at all hey subscribe for more
answers to the questions you really want
to know about if you found this video
helpful or terrifying hit like and go
ahead and comment if you genuinely
thought the trailer was for a new grand
theft auto movie like I did lies I'm
drew Coolidge and I am moving out of the
state does anyone in Wichita have a
couch I can crash on anybody